hey how's your day
deaf dads and dads don't always get
along but dusty and I have this code add
thing on lockdown
you make treats for tonight right I'll
hit the bakery on the way to patty
bakery
don't you don't over to go to the bakery
no I'm usually when you repeat what I
said and you shake your head up and down
it really means you don't want me to do
it I'm just thinking what may be
homemade
no crowd rag call me snickerdoodles come
right up hi-ho give me again you've got
a cop truck Pete thank you so much to
the cocoa hey I got a be surprised me
money to trampoline this year Christmas
both families together hello grandpa
Kurt
look your father hasn't met the new of
all dusty that's exactly the stuff he's
going to make fun of us for you'll see
dear god damn dress is so cool I can't
picture him actually going shopping
[Music]
in the station
there you go bring the car around on the
curb this is Sarah's husband whitey here
because my dad's coming in a send a long
time it's only been two weeks but it
feels like forever doesn't it
this guy's crazy your kids half the time
[Applause]
kids not going to go in for you two dead
hookers wash up okay done a real
Christmas crowd I'm telling you the only
person that can ruin your Christmas
looking back at you from that mirror all
I see is you burn sorry right here there
there we go hmm still you guys
[Music]
you